la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur jean leonetti
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
chez le premier ministre le peuple grecs
souffrent et la grèce est au bord de la
faillite
à qui la faute pas l'europe certainement
mais aux dirigeants grecs successifs et
actuelle incapable de réformer leur pays
est de collecter l'impôt
la grèce est menacée de sortir de l'euro
à qui la faute à monsieur cipra c'est
pas à l'europe qui a fait habilement
croire au grec et à son peuple que dire
non au référendum c'est dire oui à
l'europe et nos efforts or d un certain
nombre de pays européens ont fait des
efforts comme l'espagne le portugal
irlande et sont sortis des difficultés
depuis monsieur type race ne propose
rien rien depuis qu'il est élu
rien depuis le référendum et rien depuis
48 heures l'europe est affaibli à qui la
faute à l'effacement de la france et à
la disparition de la force du couple
franco-allemand qui permit à monsieur
type race de jouer au poker menteur
entre l'intransigeance de l'allemagne
et l'impuissance de la france un sondage
humiliant montre que les français font
deux fois plus confiance à la
chancelière allemande co président de la
république française pour régler le
problème grec
la france monsieur le premier ministre
n'est pas le médiateur silencieux qui
négocient en coulisses entre la grèce et
l'allemagne la france doit avoir une
voix forte
être leader être moteur de l'europe il
faut sortir du flou il faut dire ce que
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons que la
grèce reste dans le rhum et pas à
n'importe quel prix
la france doit exiger la clarté des
réformes crédibles et durables
en contrepartie de la solidarité
européenne la france doit porter un
projet européen
monsieur le premier ministre quelles
sont les propositions de la france dans
ce domaine
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député léonetti
nous avons un débat qui a été organisé à
l'initiative du bureau de l'assemblée
nationale dans une heure à cette
occasion le premier ministre pourra
évidemment devra il le fera expliquer
pleinement totalement la position de la
france même si je vais vous apporter
bien sûr quelques éléments de réponse
monsieur leonetti on peut vouloir faire
le procès d'un gouvernement d'un autre
pays
on peut vouloir faire le procès de tel
ou tel autre pays ou même du
gouvernement français nous sommes là
dans la politique politicienne
elle fait partie du débat démocratique
et elle fait partie du débat dans cette
assemblée
ce à quoi je vous appelle les uns et les
autres monsieur le député je sais que
compte tenu des qualités qui sont les
vôtres et des engagements qui sont les
vôtres vous êtes à 7 et les fonctions
qui ont été les vôtres vous êtes dans la
capacité d'être à ce niveau fonction
procès de l'histoire c'est le seul
aujourd'hui qui compte
quel pourrait être le procès de
l'histoire par rapport à l'attitude que
les uns et les autres nous prenons
aujourd'hui que veut la france que la
grèce restent non pas seulement dans
l'europe
elle est dans l'europe et dans l'euro
parce que c'est l'intérêt de la grèce et
au total c'est l'intérêt de l'europe de
la zone euro et de la france non pas
tant que nous soyons aujourd'hui menacée
par une crise économique ou financière
comme ça a pu être le cas il ya quelques
années la france est beaucoup plus forte
l'europe s'est elle-même aussi renforcée
et la crise serait d'abord elle est déjà
aujourd'hui pour la grèce mais parce que
c'est le projet européen que nous
défendons que vous défendez que nous
sommes capables de défendre ensemble
la france elle veut que la grèce reste
dans l'euro mais ça ne peut pas être
dans n'importe quelles conditions
ça ne peut l'être que si les grecs font
des propositions
si le gouvernement grec fait des
propositions c'est ce qu'il est en train
de faire et nous allons pouvoir juger
dans les minutes et dans les heures ou
dans les jours qui viennent de la
qualité de cette proposition et c'est
sur ces propositions que nous pouvons
l'année l'autre prend des
responsabilités s'ils mentionnent
ministre
la parole est